joining us now is general lord richard
dannett former head of the british army
of course thank you for joining us my
lord this morning just hearing us i'm
talking to you that norway's defense
minister saying they're sending more
troops as well to bolster nato how
likely do you think it is as of this
morning that some kind of war is likely
well good morning kate um
as alistair bunker has just reported um
the preparations by the russians and the
signs are all there
that
they could mount an attack
one of a series of potential attack um
objectives um at any time and i'm sure
that uh intelligence is absolutely right
to come to that conclusion but and
here's the critical but they may well
have the capability in place uh have
they got the intention has vladimir
putin decided that's what he wants to do
and i think that is that is the big but
as things currently stand he's captured
the attention of
all western leaders
uh we can all see he's got a significant
military forces on the ukrainian border
he's there threatening he's intimidating
he's bullying he's achieved an awful lot
of what he wants to achieve he's got the
world talking about vladimir putin but
if he attacks that lightning strike from
belarus to kiev or moving into the donex
area which is also quite quite possible
it will involve huge destruction of
ukrainian infrastructure it'll involve
large numbers of loss of life of
ukrainian soldiers and civilians and
critically it will also involve the loss
of life of of many russian soldiers and
and he'll be doing something frankly
that's out of date um the mid-20th
century we saw hitler invade parts of
europe
it used to happen in the 18th and 19th
centuries and before that is this really
something that a responsible
leader in the 21st century actually
really wants to do
from being in the strong position that
he is now he'd be the object of
appropriate criticism and vilification
right across the world does he really
want that i'll stick my neck out i stuck
it out before i don't think he does i
don't think he will make a major kind of
incursion at the very least i think what
he might do
is move into the donbass donetsk area
which
has been under dispute for quite some
time since 2014 and this would pose a
bit of a dilemma for for western leaders
will he make the major incursion no i
don't think he will he's achieved a lot
of what he wants to achieve already and
of course that comes back to ukraine not
joining nato and again i'll stick my
neck out and say as much as we admire
the ukrainians i don't believe they
should be part of nato because
spiritually and emotionally they're too
close to russia and i think it's the
provocation of the russians too far
if we do look at an incursion to the
east to the maybe south east if i'm
writing say um in dance um as opposed to
right up in the far north of uh the
country and and the capital even
apparently it's only about 120 miles or
so from the border even if the russian
troops do come in and travel all the way
to kiev what do they do then
well
you made a very good point to ask a very
good question k as always
well what do they do on the way the
answer is they will be fought
aggressively by the ukrainian armed
forces they are over 200 000 strong plus
their own militia their capability is
much greater now than it was 5 10 15
years before it
will not be a pushover for for russian
troops um okay let's assume that they
fight their way sooner or later to kiev
they fight their way up through the east
or the southeast and if you like occupy
most of the country
what is going to happen then are the
ukrainians going to accept that i don't
think they will i think unless the
russians decide to withdraw very quickly
they'll find that they've got an
insurgency on their hands that you could
argue might make afghanistan like a walk
in the park i think the ukrainians would
not accept russian troops on every
street corner russian troops dominating
and russia dominating ukraine ukraine is
a fiercely independent country it wants
to be separate from russia
and we have every responsibility to
support their right to be independent in
the same way that sweden and finland are
um to support their independence and
support them in their fights to maintain
their own territorial sovereignty and
integrity
um interestingly i spoke to um a vice
chair of the duma now historian russian
um just yesterday on the program and she
was saying i was asking about why the
troops were on the border and she was
saying that they are there to
protect russia from an invasion from
ukraine
how would you have reacted if she'd said
that to you
well um
yes okay uh right through the period of
the cold war the the line that the
soviet union always took was that they
had to have large armed forces even to
the point of crippling their own
their own economy because they wanted to
defend themselves against nato
aggression so this is the same line that
the russians are there to protect
themselves against ukrainian aggression
but i'm afraid just just take a sort of
pinch of reality
nato never had any intention of being
aggressive towards the soviet union up
to 1989 and ukraine has no intention of
being aggressive towards russia so i'm
afraid
with all due respect to that um
correspondent and commentator you were
talking to yesterday um
cloud cookie land is somewhere that
sensible people don't
inhabit and i think she might have just
bought a ticket there
um i wonder what you think about the
chair of the defense select committee
tobias elwood a former military man as
well of course he says that nato troops
should be on the ground right now in
ukraine and that putin is smelling
weakness and exploiting it what would
happen if nato troops find themselves on
the ground in ukraine
okay um i i shouldn't smile um you're
not the first person to ask me um about
tomorrow but
actually i rang tobias about 20 minutes
ago and said come on chuck what are you
getting on about um i know tobias very
well he was under my command in bosnia
in the mid 90s when we were ending
ending that war the point that tobias
was making and it was a fair point
when he was making it was that
perhaps i don't agree but perhaps
what the west should have done six
twelve months ago is realize
the threat that russia was to ukraine
and at that point not just put
training forces in
and supply them with weaponry and so on
that
there was probably a case for
a demonstrative deterrent deployment of
nato forces in ukraine to up the stakes
if you like and persuade um
vladimir putin that this would be
a very dangerous course to follow that
that's really what tobias was getting on
about when he said that there should be
have been a small number of british
troops deployed there it was a kind of
tripwire uh and also to up the stakes
for vladimir putin and what tobias is
saying now and he said to me earlier
this morning is of course now we
shouldn't be doing that but it was
something that perhaps we should have
thought about six 12 months ago on that
basis it was a fair point but the
underlying point is that ukraine
is not a member of nato i believe should
not be a member of nato i believe that
that would be a provocation to the
russians greater than is reasonable
given the
historic link between ukraine and russia
and it brings us back to the point we
absolutely support ukraine's right to be
independent
and to fight if they wish to do so and
i'm sure they will to defend their own
territory and their own sovereignty
my lord it's always great to talk to you
and it was fabulous to have your son on
the programme um at the end of last week
do you thank him
on our behalf for taking the time to
join us thank you
okay thanks all the best thank you thank
you